nothing satisfies Jack like solving a
Murder Jack was of average height with a
very typical face despite this he had
insane abs like crazy good abs and
really thick arms it was a Tuesday and
he was standing over another dead body
captain of the police force detective
Commander Jane the captain walked over
to him she had long arms and legs and
the face of a long-armed long-legged
model despite their sexual chemistry
Jack knew they could never be together
hey you she said flirtatiously hey you
also he said flirtatiously as well damn
you she said angrily how are you so good
at being detective because I used magic
he thought but instead he said reasons